I'm in college and I'm working towards
going to OCS after I graduate I work a
food service job I was try to teach a 17
year old at work why she shouldn't have
fast cleaning a fryer I said because of
unmitigated daily discipline in all
things that includes cleaning the fire
she still didn't quite get it I didn't
say to her that I make the I make the
fryer spotless because if I can't manage
to clean the fryer how can I expect
myself to lead people in the military if
so facto war because I didn't think that
I didn't think that was appropriate to
say to that a 17 year old girl I try to
lead by example but I'm not sure that is
enough how can I best explain or show my
younger co-workers why they should have
automated mitigated daily discipline in
all things when she when the stakes are
only a fryer and not lives ok let's see
we're kind of in the same vein on some
stuff tonight which is good mmm
right it's good first of all because
unmitigated daily discipline and all
things should be first and foremost
applied to you not not everyone else
around you let's start with yourself
imposing discipline on other people is
not leadership it's just an all for
authoritarian person barking orders so
to answer your question well first of
all read if you haven't read the book at
the dichotomy of leadership you might
want to check that one out there's a
couple chapters you could focus on one
of them is called resolute but not
overbearing
one of them's called disciplined but not
rigid one of them's called hold people
accountable but don't hold their hands
and this is pretty much why we had to
write the dichotomy leadership because
you're out there good on you trying to
take extreme ownership and that's great
but you're not you're not paying
attention to the dichotomy of leadership
so let me let me break it down for you a
little bit more clearly and then you can
go read the book as well which will help
you
you say that the stakes are only a clean
fryer and not lives and you're right
lives are not at stake and neither
really is the functionality of the fryer
itself because it doesn't have to be
completely spotless and in fact if
you're trying to keep it completely
spotless it might actually waste time
that she could be doing something that's
more important like prepping the
potatoes or washing her hands to keep
the food sanitary so you need to think
about that how truly important like when
you say on MIT when I say because I say
this all time and I apologize for
throwing you a little bit too far in one
direction unmitigated daily discipline
in all things there's no there's no
departure from that right that's what it
is there's no departure for that but
here's the deal if you were in the
military and you got spun up about
little things that don't really matter
you are wasting your leadership capital
and when something in actually important
it's what you were just talking about
echo when something actually important
comes up your troops aren't even gonna
listen to you because they don't know
what anything or they don't know what's
important what's not because you say
that everything is important like hey
why do I need to stay a watch why do I
need to stay awake during watch that's
not any more important to you than
whether I have a stain on my shirt
because you're freaking out about
everything so so how do I know what's
what now
here's the deal you can go too far in
the other direction you can let people
do whatever they want they completely
lack discipline and the little things do
matter the little things do matter but
you gotta remember they only matter a
little and if you waste your time and
you waste your leadership and you waste
your energy on things that don't matter
are things that matter very little then
you won't be able to lead your team when
it really counts what happens is it's a
slippery slide it's a slope it's a it's
it's a slippery slope and if you let
something slide then you let something
else slide then you let something else
side eventually got no discipline so you
have to be careful of that
but at the same time it's the other
direction what you end up in in the
other direction if you if you impose
unmitigated daily discipline in all
things you're gonna end up like um
here's a movie reference Eko Charles
Animal House sure have you seen it yes
you know okay so you don't remember
Niedermayer the ROTC guy that's yelling
at everyone you're worthless and weak
he's like that he's a guy that's just
barking and going crazy and that's a
comical example but I'll tell you what
you want a real example a real a real
good example that you can check out once
again go and watch the first episode of
the Band of Brothers series and check
out captain Sobel the company commander
of Easy Company he is hardcore and he
has he imposes absolute unmitigated
discipline and all things on his whole
company
he holds the line hmm Oh dirty weapon no
no liberty for you hmm pass revoked rust
on your knife passed revoked uniform out
of uniform
creases in your boots their creases in
your pants I pass revoked oh that guy's
doing it he's doing that unmitigated
discipline in all things and guess what
happens to him he gets fired his troops
hate to him mm-hmm he's worried about
things that don't matter
dick winners totally squared away
worries about things that are important
he and as a individual and if you
remember I don't even know if they show
this in Menna brothers but as an
individual imposing discipline on
himself guess what he's doing during the
battle the bolts bowel bulge middle the
winter snowed in don't have winter gear
they're freezing they're dying
what's winners doing in the morning he's
up and he's shaving he's getting up and
he's shaving his battalion commander cuz
I was like bro are you sure you need a
shave
he's okay just hold in line so
that's why we wrote the dichotomy
leadership this stuff is a balance and
you have to learn to balance you don't
want to end up going and ending up like
captain Sobel and I hope everybody
that's has that tendency to want to
control things and they want to use
discipline and they want to use
unmitigated daily discipline in all
things you want to use that as your
slogan to beat people down go watch the
first episode of Band of Brothers and
get your act together
yeah the fright that reminded me of when
you hmm
we're talking about your gym floor you
know yeah no you don't I mean sure you
don't want the you don't want a bag and
your dirty clothes and socks and shoes
all over the floor while you worked out
but at this for a reason yeah same way
the whole reason you got to clean the
Flyers or the fryer for a reason you
know so you know the reason is I'm not
as familiar with fryers but I'm sure
that work at Wendy's like I did I can
tell you that the external the external
cleanliness of the fryer is not a big
deal yeah like you said do you want it
to be caked with grease where it's a
fire hazard no yeah but guess what it's
a functional item that you're using all
day there's gonna be some spots on it
and if I'm freaking out about that guess
what I got somebody that's not washing
their hands or even worse I got someone
that's intentionally sabotaging the food
so we get bad reviews now we're going
out of business
yeah or whatever yeah so it's
essentially like hey man identify they
use the the optimal use of the fryer
and let's target that is like the right
way to clean it kind of thing you know
and that's sort of it like don't you
don't have to sweep your gym floor and
mop it and make sure it you can see your
face in the I'm getting more chocolate
thing in 23 hours yeah 22 hours right it
makes no difference
yeah to why I have a gym floor you have
the gym floor so I can drop weights and
walk that's it kind of thing not so you
know I can I don't know be super
discipline wasting my time mopping it
and you know all this stuff because I'm
unmitigated daily discipline in all
things you know functionality you have
to uphold imagine how many hours
my life I would have thrown away if I
was mopping cleaning sweeping and
vacuuming my gym floor every day when I
it would take as long as my workout or
take probably 20 minutes I guess yeah so
there's there's what almost two hours a
week to a little over two hours a week
gone gone you think I got two hours a
week think about what two hours two
hours is like a massive amount of time
yeah that's a that's a good two hours is
a huge amount of time unless give that
away
you own a commercial gym then you want
to mop that floor because it adds to the
functionality I'm getting members you
know you're gonna do you know you're
gonna give the floor is gonna be clean
yeah
but guess what here's go to the extreme
hey we just cleaned that floor don't
walk on it shut down you know because we
just mopped it it's like no yeah you
just mopped it we're gonna use it yeah
so it's kind at the end of the day it's
kind of like what unmitigated daily
discipline in all things that what that
are functional that are functional for
sure that are are for yourself for put
that on yourself you put that on
yourself and here's what here's you
really want to take this to the next
level yes be disciplined in how you
impose discipline on people don't just
let it run wild do you have to have
discipline in it that's the way it is
yeah yeah it kind of does some paint
that picture how you're every time I get
these questions it's like I'm so happy
we wrote the dichotomy leadership
because there's the answer yeah that's
the answer the answer is this all this
is a dichotomy everything is there and
people don't want it to be an economy
because it's dichotomies are complex
dichotomies are hard dichotomies take it
takes skill to learn to balance and it
takes awareness of the situation yeah
it's hard it's so much easier to say oh
you just impose your discipline and make
everyone do you want to do you can't do
that you'll end up with a mutiny my
second platoon that went when we had a
mutiny we worked for a guy that made us
do everything his way mm-hmm my way or
the highway guess what
didn't work mutiny cos it was a highway
but not for us
yeah and not a bad guy it wasn't a bad
guy we didn't have bad intentions mm-hmm
but that's where this guy is heading
he's had an OCS and if he keeps with
that attitude he's gonna end up in those
situations that's beautiful I'm so glad
he asked this question mm-hmm
because I'm glad he asked his question
because it's not his fault he's
listening to what I said and I didn't
communicate it well enough so now he
asked a great question and now he can
take a much much better approach a much
more balanced approach in his leadership
yeah
like flying a kite Kenna your kite I had
flown a kite but what this has nothing
to do with fun no but the fundamental
principle right you know yeah Noel
depends on what kind of kite I get it
but you know time with the two handles
and the two strings you know you gotta
see I'm saying you got to kind of pull
one and let one go a little bit and then
it depends on the wind you know it
depends on how strong the wind is and
you gotta pull curl let blackout from
telling you our flight night just flew
on like maybe like you know five six
seven weeks ago it's good windy day cool
by the way